[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning the
tributes they are pouring in this
morning for Nick Cordero the Broadway
star who has lost a 3-month battle with
the corona virus died over the weekend
he was just 41 when he died yesterday at
a Los Angeles hospital his wife Amanda
cludes wrote on Instagram this he was
surrounded in love by his family singing
and praying as he gently left this earth
on Twitter
Hamilton creator lin-manuel Miranda
called the news devastating Cordero's
former Broadway co-star Zach Braff wrote
I can honestly tell you I have never met
a kinder human being
[Music]
Nick Cordero was known for his soulful
baritone
and versatile vocals the 41 year old
made his Broadway debut back in 2012 and
later went on to originated the role of
mob boss Sonny in the stage production
of Chazz Pullman Terry's a Bronx Tale in
2014 he was nominated for a Tony Award
for playing the menacing gangster
teach-in bullets over Broadway he and
his wife Amanda cludes first met as cast
mates in that musical they later had a
son elvis is extremely weak muscles
defeats I spoke to Amanda coots last
Monday about her husband's condition
what have you been told Amanda about the
effects of the body of a long intubation
oh gosh Gail it's hard I mean the longer
you're in ICU the longer on a ventilator
your body's more susceptible to
infection and that is what we're seeing
with Nik he is in and out of attractions
in his lungs in his blood the 41 year
old Broadway actor was placed in a
medically induced coma three months ago
we really need Nick to wake up and start
some healing as a public rallied around
him and his recovery
Cordero woke up from that coma but
suffered setback after setback in April
doctors amputated his right leg due to
coronavirus complications to fully
recover
Lutz told us he's need an even more
significant surgery
our ultimate Nick ultimately lost his
battle with the corona virus after 95
long days in the hospital I was
wondering Amanda if you've ever gone
there have doctors told you Amanda it's
time to let him go have they ever said
that to you
I believe Gail that God is the only
person that's going to decide when I win
and if my husband goes so I I will never
try to play that role but to his fans
his friends and his family
he will always be a bright light that
can never be put out mmm it's so hard
guys looking at that interview just one
week ago we sat down and talked with her
she had told us at that time she had
been told four different times that this
was it to get ready but she said he kept
rallying and rallying and she said as
long as he was fighting she was gonna
fight too but I can't say enough how
much I admire her and how much I care
about her her enthusiasm was so
infectious she gave us all such faith in
hope and it's so hard to believe that
this battle is over it's really really
tough to take that in you know when I
see the video of him singing and dancing
so full of life that is what is so hard
to watch and the one thing I'm heartened
by guys is that little Elvis will know
how much his father was loved the people
who sang his music his former castmates
who that hashtag wake up Nick he will
know that as he gets older that is true
that that's a good thing to focus on
yeah we're gonna add something yes you
know what else look yes little Elvis
will also know because she's got video
of how much his father loved him to
Elvis turned one June 10th just think
about that for a second Nick was six
five the picture of health when I asked
her in our first interview how do you
think he got it she really doesn't know
she said they had spent every moment
together the only time they were
separated is when they took two
different flights from coast to coast
and that's the only thing they could
think of is that he must have gotten it
on an airplane but again she doesn't
know nobody really knows but to hear
that you know this is not this is a
harmless this is a harmless disease it's
just not true it can strike you in he
was a picture of health the picture of
health no underlying conditions so you
just never know how it can affect you
you just don't you are absolutely right
Gail that's the takeaway for me as well
it's a beautiful remembrance thank you
very much